you might think pixar's luca is just
another hit
animated film but a look behind the
curtain reveals that it's
not just a movie about two teen sea
monsters it's
so much more it's a motion picture that
shows us
years of historical italian legends and
personal experiences from the director
himself
that all led to the true meaning behind
luca ready to find out what that meaning
is
luca is yet another historical moment
for disney and pixar it's their first
film
ever to solely focus on italian culture
and heritage
as you can imagine that means a lot of
what we see transpire to luca and
alberto
as well as the setting has a real-life
basis sure
porto rosso isn't a real italian town
however it's a near replica of the
italian fishing towns located in the
italian riviera
as for the sea monsters they exist too
at least in the legends of the italian
people
everyone portrays pretends to believe in
sea monsters
when talking about the inspiration
behind the sea monsters director enrico
casarosa said
there's a big history of sea dragons for
example one is in san franco which has
the famous abbey
it's a beautiful place that we
definitely took a lot of reference from
a place that is known for a dragon that
lives there along with the sea dragons
there were stories of friendly octopuses
and feisty krakens that even had
references in the film
kind of sounds interesting when it came
to designing the sea monsters they
pulled out old italian sea maps and took
reference of their illustrations
however they did have to tone down those
illustrations a little when they saw it
become
overpowering in the film enrico said in
the beginning
we were drawing them really fantastical
we were fascinated by all these fins and
all this
weird and kind of decorative elements on
them in the sea maps
but it was like no they're attracting
too much attention to themselves
things like the fins on the fish and the
variety between them all came from those
old historical items
according to production designer
danielle strichlava
they wanted to make sure they kept the
inspiration from the maps but also
be sure they were able to modify them in
order to fit each sea monster's
personality or home
the filmmakers even made sure that their
underwater scenes were in line with the
aquatic life in the mediterranean waters
and more specifically
ligurian sea isn't it great
plenty of research and personal
experience went into the making of the
film and luca as a character
in fact luca and alberto are loosely
based on a friendship enrico had while
growing up in italy
he credits his past bff for helping him
come out of his shell and get him where
he is today
his family wasn't very present he
couldn't do whatever he wanted
it was the perfect friendship to get me
out of my comfort zone and help me grow
up
what does that mean no idea go find out
for me will ya
the location was also chosen based on
enrico's childhood the director would
visit the italian riviera during the
summer months and his fond memories of
the towns were the reason for the
setting of luca
but of course enrico couldn't rely on
solely his own memories to create a
movie on italian culture
who wants to watch me eat a big sandwich
although he was raised there he spent
the majority of his adult life in
america
that being said he put together a team
of art designers and sent them on a
mission to italy where they were tasked
with getting to know the culture
food and art in the country eriksen
thinks it's so important to get the
feeling of the place
the light and the details it has so much
history
the goal visually of creating luca was
to be able to transport people to this
beautiful place that you would love to
visit for real
but that you can visit through luca
that's how we're gonna see the world
overall the goal of luca was to portray
the epic bonds of friendship
enrico wanted to make sure that the
movie's main symbolism of the importance
of friendship was at the forefront and
not
sacrificed for added drama they even cut
certain scenes to make sure they kept it
in line with the vision
we had much more of a quest and we had a
huge kraken transformation at the end
a big monster finish we realized that
wasn't the story we wanted to tell
all in all he was going for a stand by
me in italy vibe
luca represented the confusing and
challenging times we all experience when
we're 13.
the frustration of not identifying with
your true self or unsure how to express
who you want to be to others
luca disguising himself was actually a
metaphor for that situation
and another extension of enrico's
personal experience
your life is so much cooler than mine
those years where you feel odd in your
own body and you don't fit in for many
different reasons
so something felt right talking about
that age with the setting of a
changeling
someone actually hiding his true self
naturally because he has to
the contrast between the murky ocean
waters and wide and never-ending human
lands also helped showcase the cramped
feeling luca was experiencing
as a sea monster you just sit on it and
it takes you anywhere you want to go
then they were able to tie in the iconic
italian vespa to represent the freedom
luca had as a human
fespa is freedom the art team's research
and enrico's personal experience
definitely paid off they created a film
that not only gave representation to the
beautiful italian culture
but a film about friendship and growing
pains that people around the world can
relate to
what did you love about luca thanks for
watching